[موسيقى]
داخل مختبر أبحاث الهندسة الميكانيكية في جامعة ستانفورد ،
ابتكارات
مثيرة تتشكل
هذه الوحدات هي نفس نمط الأوريغامي الذي يمكن
لكل منها طيه في الواقع ويمكنه
الوصول إلى أنه يمكن أن
يتفاعل مع الكائن عن طريق الانحناء
واللف
باستخدام شكل معين من
تجميع الأوريغامي  يعمل
البروفيسور رينيه جاو ، المعروف باسم نمط
الكريسلينج ، على تصميمات
ذراع
آلية جديدة ، حيث يحاكي التصميم ذراع الأخطبوط الذي
يُعتبر عمومًا أحد أكثر
الأطراف مرونة في كل الطبيعة ، حيث
يمكن للأذرع التحرك في أي اتجاه.
من خلال تكرار هذه الحركات في
فك ذراع آلي يعتقد أنه قد يساعد يومًا ما
أطباء غرفة الطوارئ على توفير
الأكسجين للمرضى الذين يعانون
حاليًا في تطبيق الطب الحيوي ، تكون
عملية التنبيب صعبة
لأنه من الصعب الوصول إلى القصبة الهوائية ، يمكننا
استخدام مجال الحجم لتوجيه
عملية الحدس
ويمكن أن يكون جانب الطي والتمدد للروبوت
طبيعيًا  متوافق مع
حركة القصبة الهوائية
بالنسبة للبروفيسور أكسفورد أدريان توماس ، فإن
احتمال استخدام الروبوتات بدلاً من
مشرط الجراح هو
تقدم مثير في
الطب تم تجربته واختباره على مدار
مئات السنين ولكن الطريقة التي
يعمل بها جراحو المهنة الطبية داخل
منزلك  الجسد وما زال هو
نفسه تمامًا يحصلون على شفرة ويقطعونك
بفتح
أنه يجب أن تكون هناك طريقة أفضل
داخل مختبر zhao يعمل طلاب هندسة المختبرات
على تطوير مجموعة من
الروبوتات الصغيرة التي قد تعيد تشكيل الطريقة التي
يعالج بها الأطباء المرضى قريبًا.  طباعة مقطع
أوريغامي بلاستيكي
وتجميعه يدويًا في وحدة واحدة قابلة للطي
بعد ذلك يمكن للطابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد بثق
راتينج بوليمر يحتوي
على جزيئات مغناطيسية على لوح زجاجي يمنح
كل وحدة قطبية مغناطيسية
وتوفر القوة الدافعة
للتنقل في الروبوت
مرة واحدة داخل الجسم ، يكون الفنيون
قادرين على التعامل مع الروبوت باستخدام
مجال مغناطيسي حتى الإصدار  الشيء الجميل
في هذا التصميم هو أننا نستخدم
مجموعة واحدة فقط من المجالات المغناطيسية ، ولكن بمجرد
تغيير حجمها واتجاهها ،
يمكننا التحكم بشكل انتقائي في الوحدة التي
نريدها لتحريك
ذراع الأخطبوط ، وهي واحدة فقط من عدة
تصميمات Zhao وفريقها هم  تطوير
يمكن أن يكون له تطبيقات طبية حيوية واسعة
في أبريل عمل جاو مع ما يسمى
بالروبوت الزاحف بناءً على
حركات دودة الأرض على غلاف
مجلة التقدم العلمي.
عالم zhao للميكانيكا الحيوية ، دودة الأرض هي
نجم روك قام الإنسان الآلي الزاحف
بتطويره مؤخرًا بحيث يكون مستوحى من
حركة دودة الأرض ، ولديه صلابة منخفضة جدًا
في الاتجاه المتحرك
وصلابة عالية جدًا في الاتجاه الجانبي
للتغلب على المقاومة
من الفضاء الضيق.
الآن يتم تصميم الروبوت الزاحف
لتقديم مسكنات الألم
بشكل أكثر فاعلية عن طريق أخذ الدواء مباشرة
إلى موقع الألم.
يمكن دمج كاميرا
فوقها حتى نتمكن من رؤية الأشياء
التي يمكنك رؤية ما بداخلها بالفعل ، لذلك
هناك الكثير من
الوظائف المختلفة التي يمكن دمجها
في نظام الروبوت المعدني
في معهد ماكس بلانك
للأنظمة الذكية في شتوتغارت بألمانيا.
نعمل على تصميم روبوت ميلي آخر تم
تصميمه على غرار
حركات كاتربيلر بين الكائنات الحية
الأخرى بالإضافة إلى توصيل الأدوية ، ونأمل
في يوم من الأيام أن يقوم الروبوت الذي يبلغ طوله أربعة مليمترات
بإجراء الخزعات واستبدال
الحاجة إلى العمليات الجراحية الغازية بينما تكون
الاحتمالات لأشكال جديدة من
العلاج  من المؤكد أن الأسئلة المثيرة للاهتمام لا
تزال قائمة
أولاً ، كيف سيقوم الأطباء بإزالة الروبوت
من الجسم بمجرد الانتهاء من
مهمته ، تقول تشاو إن مختبرها يبحث في
الأمر
بطريقة واحدة وهي تطوير مادة قابلة للتحلل الحيوي
تكون متوافقة تقريبًا ، إنها
آمنة جدًا ويمكن أن يتحلل الروبوت
بعد انتهائه  جميع مهام
بحث جايلز حاليًا في مرحلة التجربة
ومن المحتمل أنها لا تزال بعيدة  من
التجارب السريرية البشرية
في الوقت الحالي ، تواصل Zhao البحث عن
طرق جديدة لتحسين نماذج الأوريغامي
التي تطورها في بحثها الطبي الحيوي
مستوحاة من الذكاء
الموجود في الطبيعة وتوسيع
حدود ما هو ممكن حاليًا